sometimes i love going on my dad's
instagram he doesn't really know how to
control hands yeah his thumbs are so big
sometimes he hits the wrong things yeah
no you don't like shrek's hands the same
flash
can't talk can you stutter one more time
do she sells seashells by the seashore
sea shells no she she she sells
seashells by the seashore there you go
thank you dad we'd be really
disappointed
i hope he doesn't watch this episode
what the [ __ ] is going on i like to
party jesus honey
this is unwaxed
we're going shopping with sophia and
sistine stallone do we just become best
friends
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwax podcast
with your favorite sisters sophia and
sistine sophia and i were talking the
other day actually she texted me and she
goes to steen i'm watching our old
episodes right now and i'm laughing and
yes that may sound a little narcissistic
laughing at herself but you know what
we were proud of the cause
no i'm telling you when we were
bambi-eyed wide-eyed really excited to
start a podcast we were super super
enthusiastic at every single segment we
put our heart and soul not that we don't
do it anymore but i feel like we really
really brought it and it was so goofy
maybe it was because we felt like at
that time no one was listening so you
could just say stupid [ __ ] and
no one no i care and now i think we're a
little bit more oh let's just
refine what we're saying and make our
transitions more seamless but we thought
you know what
let's bring back all of our og segments
so if you guys are a true listener we're
gonna open this episode with our wax and
wayne of the week and then we're going
to follow up with bedtime stories and
maybe an unsolicited advice yeah yeah so
we're going to get into our wax away to
wax and wayne is our highs and lows if
you all don't know do you want to start
off i will start off so uh sophie and i
just got back from oklahoma right and
we'll get into that in a second you guys
are probably wondering why the hell we
would be in oklahoma yeah that's that's
a story in itself my wax of the week was
i got back on a horse yeah she's been
dying to get back on that i got back i
you know served that [ __ ] and i wrote
it and it was
amazing i honestly forgot how much i
enjoyed it and i was a little bit
nervous because i was working with this
new trainer and she's a pro she was
really serious about what she does and
also i went to train during one of these
huge competitions so everyone around me
in the arena was like professional level
runners and here i am
haven't ridden a horse in a while
all right let's see if i remember i
thought it was going to be like riding a
bike it was [ __ ] let me tell you cocky
smashed it she killed it she killed it i
believe her i mean mom and dad were
there so they said that you did really
well we used to ride a lot when we were
younger and it was something that my dad
used to do my mom used to do so kind of
naturally us we got into it yeah i never
performed because i had performance
anxiety
you quit quite soon i'm not gonna lie i
did i'm not bad but you were the one
that really pursued it and tried it so
badass there's something about being
in cowboy attire riding a horse they
were like i am unstoppable no no we went
to a literal cowboy shop and the things
that the steam bought
our boy juan
he was giving us so many compliments
gave me the the drippiest drip ever for
western range she looked so she looked
country she has like little roses on she
was like yellowstone hit me up yeah it
was me in the show oh yeah i brought an
embroidered rhinestone shirt
you got it what am i gonna wear on a
horse i guess that's it um another wax
just to throw in there another wax cake
boss my buddy
my buddy buddy he follows us on
instagram i saw it i saw it can i just
say i this shows how often i am on
instagram i saw the immediate second he
followed because i saw that blue check
mark i go there's no way i've been a fan
of the show since i was 15. i think i've
watched every episode every day say it
say it my name is buddy i'm the boss and
then he goes
these are my crew me and familia
i'm just so excited why don't you follow
us why i don't know it was like
immediately he followed all three of us
really i don't know if he follows dad or
not i think he does but i saw and i
called today i was like sistine get
ready to have your world rocked i know i
remember when i was 16 for my 16th
birthday i called his shop in new jersey
and this was the peak when he was
starting in like pogba he was prime
i called a shop in jersey and i was like
listen i need to talk to your sister
mary and so mary gets on the phone she's
like hello
and i'm like mary i need a cake she goes
what kind of cake do you want and i said
i need it to be a bust of my head
because they do weird [ __ ] like that and
they didn't ship to la no so you got on
the phone with buddy i did i don't know
how i finished you she finished her way
from
the storefront to the sister to buddy
themselves so buddy if you're listening
we really appreciate the follow that was
probably one of our highlights of the
year it was my wax so here's my wane of
the week want wayne
if you guys don't know i'm very
superstitious
and something that is um real is
apparently when you have a cowboy hat
you cannot put it on your bed really it
is severe bad luck
like ask any cowboy it's written in on
honestly every country show they're like
don't put it on the bed it's cursed
right mm-hmm i accidentally put my
cowboy hat on my bed
the night before the next morning what
did i do
slipped in dog [ __ ]
like didn't like walk in it like slip
let's ass hit the ground i'm cursed she
heals at me for not picking it up and
get this so i'm walking i slip in it i
was like god damn it i clean it up turn
the corner step in another pile i was
like this
yeah
when you have five people and three
cavapoos in like one small no i'm cursed
yeah you are cursing i mean you've been
having a lot of good luck lately but
like that was the curse of the morning
yes so what are your waxes in life all
right my wax is i almost i'm hitting 20k
on my book club so if you guys want to
follow it
photos of like actually me reading the
book that i'm reading that well i think
it's more like you just look sexy
like it's a hot girl sitting in like
pajamas like reading a book and they're
like angled really
hot girl i hate that um but i'm really
happy i mean i just didn't ever think
that i could even hit close even 15 like
i just thought that it would be like ten
thousand like some friends and like kind
of just people it's no but it's cool to
see something that you started on your
own and it's growing yeah and it's been
a year so i'm pretty proud of myself and
with my wayne my wayne is i was walking
on the beach and i kicked a rock and my
toenail slipped and sliced in half yep
so i have half a toenail i'm sorry yeah
i have half a toenail right now it
really hurt i didn't say anything i was
in severe pain i hope wikifeed is
listening they're down they're gonna
lower your radar they're gonna find my
foot pick of my current toe i'm telling
you i understand now
toenail torture you know how people used
to like rip off fingernails and toenails
people to be a form of torture they
would yeah bamboo seeds
in your fingernail buds and then bamboo
grows like at rapid pace so then it'd be
a slow torch you would like split all of
your nails off yeah so i get it why do i
know that because i think dad told us
that that that means all the weird
torture oh my god people you know he's
very into like viking torture methods
yeah um what's it called the eagle when
they like pull all of the organs and
then they make it look like wings on the
outside oh but you're still alive yes
and then the horse pulling you in like
four directions or like slowly ripping
yeah yeah but i understand toenail
torture i wouldn't want that to happen
to me
i got out a little bit and i was i was
with a couple people and i didn't want
to be that annoying person like crying
and so i just kind of sat there in
silent pain well do it like a little
favor i think do the general public a
favor and please wear closed-toed shoes
yeah well i was on the beach so
i i mean i'm assuming i would make it
better
yeah i mean why would you wear shoes on
on sand that's kind of weird honestly
that's a red flag why are you wearing
sneakers on the beach
take off your shoes feel the sand on
your feet
it's just like a fun fact
like girly quotes take up your shoes
feel the same live laugh love feel the
sand on your feet should we talk about
waves on this oklahoma yes let's get
into oklahoma so we went to oklahoma
because our dad is shooting there with
um paramount doing this thing called
tulsa king and which is super cool
shooting as well and scarlett's on the
set too and she's playing this barista
and she's cute and she's very much
perfect for the role yeah she kind of
loves it she's got like a little tattoo
and yeah
honestly i'm a little scared that she'll
follow through with the exact aesthetic
of her character but of course of course
we go when it's this severe heat wave we
have going on so it was not only just
deserted basically there was maybe like
two restaurants in our 10 mile radius it
was 111 degrees every day there was a
high of 118. i didn't actually know
human flesh could stand that heat no our
dog's paws were burnt we had to carry
our dogs over the asphalt because we
didn't want them to be no it honestly
felt like someone was holding a blow
dryer two inches from your face when you
stepped outside yeah it was horrible
like i remember the first day i landed
my mom and sister were like do not
shower the whole day like you are gonna
be going outside and inside and you will
be immediately drenched so sweaty it was
and it was humid too by the way so what
did you think of the food there i tried
to warn you i've been to oklahoma city
before
well this is the thing this girl's a
health she's a healthy girl
so are you we're all healthy people in
our family but the thing is is that
the food if i was going for
i don't really care mode i don't i think
it would have been better but i mean i
care about my health and i'm just still
trying to stay in shape
no options maybe one beet salad
and that's it i eat beet salad for the
last four days everything is battered
deep fried deep fried which is great
french fries it's not a problem the
grease is fantastic you do want a suey
right after you eat it because it is
just well this is the thing is that you
have this severely greased up
calorie filled meal
but
you can't walk yes you can exercise
there's no gym in the building first of
all and then you can't walk outside
because you'll melt
and so
what are you gonna do well you did go to
a museum one day i did go to a museum
that was really cool that was the hack
finding areas that you could visit that
were american and that was a huge museum
it was this like cowboy museum and they
showed every type of saddle every type
of rain every type of or really country
boy
yeah but it was actually so cool there
was art there was a life-size arena of
like how a rodeo would go so people
could see the
how big a
whatever if it was a bowl or a horse or
whatever it is yeah how big it is and
how crazy that like whole energy would
be and so we it was just my dad and i so
i had a great time my dad almost bought
um he bought more belt buckles i don't
know why he doesn't wear belt buckles
but he almost bought us a huge like
sombrero hat which i thought was quite
genius because i'm like it's hot makes
sense i liked that but i noticed that
they had a banjo museum there just a
museum full of banjo see this place is
this place is wild if you guys learn
about experience something just
different
go to oklahoma but i'll tell you this
everyone is so nice there that's so true
everyone is so nice they honestly made
me sad coming back to l.a same because
everyone's an [ __ ] here yes truly by
the way first of all no traffic
three o'clock it was like one car on the
street it was so nice on saturday that
was like the high time for people to go
out there was maybe i saw a total of 10
people you actually won't see more than
one car at a stop light no
it was insane insane but the people were
so nice and everyone just didn't
worry you know i feel like here i'm
always in a rush or a worry or i'm like
thinking about something else or someone
else or
where to be but like you're there it's
just so well it's awesome you know when
you go out to dinner in l.a like not
saying you have to you know dress up or
put on makeup but you know
you have to look good i do
so but i feel like i have to sometimes
because if i look bummed then i of
course i run into someone i know and i'm
like oh my god but in oklahoma you could
literally look like a wet rat yeah and
so does everyone else
and it's amazing because no one gives a
[ __ ] no one gives a [ __ ] she can't call
people
i call myself a white rat you can't call
everyone else
[Music]
doesn't think everyone looks like a
white rat she's just saying everyone's
sweaty so if
if there's like a wet rack community
that comes after me then like i'll be
shocked there's no way we have to
justify that comment right now being
like sorry if i offended anyone
in oklahoma
like what do you mean this is my [ __ ]
like apology i'm sorry
[Music]
i do have to say the women there
so nice there were some okc girlies that
came up to me and were like listen
i love your girls gotta eat episode and
i was like that's her like sexual
episode and i told them that i was like
you listen to the podcast i was telling
you all about vibrators for like 40
minutes they'd get off
oklahoma city girls get it let me tell
you i love you guys i'm coming back i'm
coming back
and just to hang out with you guys yeah
honestly i have to yeah cause let me
tell you in life no friends oklahoma
city tons of friends
i think we want to start a new life
there
jesus christ okay um so am i really red
right now
do i have enough concealer on that it's
like hiding it's my makeup splotchy oh
god okay i'm okay okay that was fun um
all right let's move on oh oh oh this is
actually really funny the last thing
about okc but it's not even about okc
but
i'm sitting on the couch with my mom and
my sisters and i don't know why but
sometimes i love going on my dad's
instagram because he he doesn't really
know how to control hands yeah his
thumbs are so big sometimes he hits the
wrong things but he i don't think he
realizes that people can see what he's
doing sometimes like if he comments on
somebody if he likes something like that
those always cause like controversy
sly's put on like x game mode is
instagram i know he's
by the way like he'll repost the story
like 12 times not realizing it's the
same video 12 times no
yeah he does that and he's also like
that crazy ex-girlfriend when like you
break up with him he'll be like yeah
you're gonna do that here's this ugly
picture of you yeah like he's so pretty
no he's like he's like a 15 year old
girl but i go on his following because
i'm like why did his follower count like
just rapidly increase like who the hell
is people you follow me on instagram
i
never laughed so hard in my life first
off he's following all these really
random like golfer like people girls
guys like everything that have like me
which is fine
why are you following them and then
second off i saw he followed like two
brad pitt fan pages he follows brad pitt
fan accounts i was like
what why is he that's so so
fantastic so sophia calls him and she
goes dad why are you following you know
not only that he follows like rottweiler
puppies and like and like a little dog
he also follows those like really
satisfying like
popping like peeling off the nose people
like doing um like fixing asphalt like
perfectly symmetrical i don't know
like perfectly cleaning a window yeah
with all the soot
it follows like eight travel pages like
like it's like called like beautiful
destinations so sophia calls him out and
she goes dad why are you following a
brad patrick what the what are you
talking about i'm not following brad
pitt get this [ __ ] off my page and i was
like so you were stalking a bradford
panic out and then you accidentally
followed it
and you were weirdo i don't have like
that many followers so they're probably
thinking about it they don't follow him
back for one thing which is so so
embarrassing
imagine being in that fan page that like
little girl that loves brad pitt or guy
whatever and it's like why sylvester
still
follow me to my fan page
his fat fingers just can't control those
yeah why does he have such big big
thumbs i don't know like an ogre yeah no
you know like shrek's hands the same
can you stutter one more time
dude i didn't sleep last night she sells
seashells by the seashore i feel like
you're seashells she shells i feel like
her esses are a little funky sea shells
no she
she sells seashells by the seashore
there you go thank you dad would be
really disappointed
i hope he doesn't watch this episode i
think you're tweaking right now because
we did something kind of intense
yesterday yeah
that i freaking love so
y'all know we've had this psychic on
twice right chris medina and some of you
guys obviously don't care about like
what our psychic reading is but he is so
spot on on things and so i was like
sistine we just haven't seen him in a
bit let's get a private reading he's the
best his name is chris medina please go
check him out if you want an ins in like
amazing reading go to him like he is
going to get scary accurate with details
and so what he says to me he says send
me photos of your most recent pick of
yourself and then send me photos of
people that you want to know more about
maybe it's a boyfriend or a girlfriend
or your dad or your mom or your friend
and he basically will tell you what your
relationship will look like also
predictions of what will happen in the
future like he also predicted something
about our career that we thought would
happen last year he's like that's gonna
fall through you're not gonna trust them
it's gonna happen this year he's never
been he's never missed never wrong
but this reading was scary specifically
scary scary freaky voodoo
kooky yeah when i say i sent photos of
like
people i dated all this stuff and he got
into the specifics i don't know how he
knew it because it wasn't like something
you can just look up and find out about
someone sofia will talk about it more
later yeah but it was pretty wild it was
wild he said i'm going to have a very
very great october he says you're gonna
be fine if you're gonna
i mean when am i not i'm getting i'm not
right now but i mean october was my peek
what he told me was freaky
was yeah that was really freaky
well he took a photo of your boyfriend
he said he saw a foot of my boyfriend
and this is what i was most nervous
about because every time i've showed him
me like a stupid fluke in the past and i
was like
is it gonna work knowing it's not he was
like absolutely not like he's never said
yes and we'll give you any reason why it
would not work right
so i sent in this photo and i was like
if he says something bad i'm gonna get
in my head and then i'm gonna tell him
and then he's gonna freak out he looks
at the phone and goes babe
what do you want me to say that's bad i
see nothing wrong and then started
listening off all these things and i was
like oh great happy then he got into
specifics and he said
this person likes to surprise you with
little things they like to surprise you
with small gifts or flowers or saying
how they feel that's sort of a big deal
he's going to tell you something
soon and i know exactly what he's going
to tell you but
i i just don't want to ruin it for you i
want it to be a surprise for you and i
was like okay chris whatever
later that night
i have a very
serious
very good relationship talk but he
brings the boyfriend and he he initiates
i never said anything to him because i
didn't want to freak this kid out
and what chris predicted which i won't
tell you guys but i will soon what chris
predicted was exactly what my boyfriend
said
and then when i told my boyfriend that
the psychic predicted that he didn't
believe me i had to call sophia to fact
check yeah it was it was pretty wild i
mean the only thing i know is that he
told me stop overthinking if we all knew
that i mean i could i i know that
stranger could tell he's like you need
to like stop overthinking and live your
life more freely i'm like i've been
doing this for 25 years tell me how to
like get out of that mind she's like
baby girl i know what this is this is
like who i am but whatever it was just
freaky accurate he predicted things
about her that happened in the past that
like yeah you would know when i mean i'm
the only one that wouldn't know so i
like i was down in my dumps
that's not right
i was down in the dumps i was down in my
dump i was down in mud dumps a few
months ago and i never really talked
about um it publicly so no one knew
what i was going through or what i was
feeling
and he looks at me and goes
cysteine
are you doing are you feeling feeling
better than you were like two months ago
like and i just got and then he got
detailed about that and i was like
you're a witch yeah it's pretty crazy
honestly i know we're
very i know we're being very um
ambiguous not very very specific very
very vague because they're very personal
things but definitely check them out we
love you chris we're for sure gonna i
feel like i'm gonna go to him for
everything now and i don't want to rely
on him but he's always right yeah he
does he doesn't miss um sofia and i
have been freaking out
because uh
love island uk
season eight
is the [ __ ] it's so good it's it's so
good so good i got text
sit bars in the develop kissed
over you today i need a new host i need
a new co-host
okay let me just no it is drama
everyone's hot this season i think
everyone has a weird name eckensou
davide i mean i don't understand
anyone's name
but let me tell you they're all hot the
lingo is so great and it's so weird like
can you imagine if you go on a date with
someone the first question that comes
out of each girl or guy's mouth is
right so like what's your type and
they're like
like tall dark and handsome like they
that's all they ask
they're like good bum nice teeth
teeth
no i i'm shot it's so good but i
actually feel really bad for one of the
islanders who so
paige no her name is coco
don't tell me no i'm not telling you
anything i feel really bad i saw wait
who's coco are we on the same scene yes
she's in the um the other with the she's
one of the new girls in the castle
she's the dark brunette one so she okay
basically
if you don't watch the show we don't
ruin anything i'm not ruining anything
shush the boys and girls get separated
and they bring on like five new guys
five new girls to test everyone's
relationships
really explaining it bad basically
everyone comes literally not at all no
no everyone couples up and they've been
living in the same house for 10 weeks
together they've been sharing a bed
everyone's pretty set they're like wow i
love you i see you dating me on the
outside and it's getting all serious
then they take all the girls put them in
a new house with six new guys and then
put six new girls in the original house
now it's testing the relationships
they're even hotter than their current
relationships and all the guys are
[ __ ] up and that's what
you should go off of now yeah so then at
the end of the week
okay thank you sistine at the end of the
week you see whether or not your partner
from the original
house stays with you or changed but
that's not the point so one of the new
girls from the new house with the boys
is in coco and she i think and i think
she ends up going and staying a little
bit longer in the show
um i think but
my god this girl has been getting
so much hate online really they've never
seen in love island history this much
hate about someone's looks she's getting
rammed about being called like ugly like
why did she make it why are these guys
liking her like incredibly horrible hate
i do have to say and she was crying on
an interview i do have to say that
actually has been a repeating thing when
it comes to love island contestants for
some reason
the trolling with them
is that you keep track so hard on these
people it's so magnified and it's kind
of sad because these aren't famous
people they're not used to
a lot of instagram following or people
commenting on their twitter like they're
just regular people and then they go
into this house with no phones no
connections to the outside world and
then they come out and see
thousands of comments think about your
life not being in the public eye and
then you're confident about your looks
like people like you for you and then
all of a sudden you come out and
everyone thinks you're ugly you're true
like why do you guys like you and she
was crying she was like i never thought
i was ugly and now and she was started
crying she's like i've never felt so low
in my life oh my god and it's really sad
like i i mean i don't know if i could
handle
that i mean maybe i could but like maybe
i can't you have to have a lot of
thick skin yeah you gotta have this well
it's crazy because these people go in
with like 600 followers right yeah they
come out with two million yeah like it
just their lives completely change i i
think a lot of the guys in the house are
not
not good i don't i don't think there's
one boy i really like let me tell you
honestly
there's two men in the room right now
i'm looking at you guys
right when you dangle something sparkly
and new in front of their faces
immediately
especially in this show they're like i'm
turning heads i've got to crack on with
the newborn do me i've got to do me i
have a good experience it's my
experience and a kiss won't mean
anything like a little cuddle and a kiss
whatever
you want it means everything i mean it's
like you just had this girl that you
professed your love to and then now
there's this cute little bombshell
that's entered the villa and like
where's your girl i know speaking of
cheating what emily ratowski
my husband the
actual f is going on the nanny
apparently
emily ratatowski gets cheated on let me
like
emily ratakowski gets cheetah on which
is crazy coming out of my mouth
by that bloke
with a nanny
i know and it's really sad because you
know you've met her and you said she was
really sweet so nice
she is such a nice person yeah like
honestly so sweet she's one of those
people where
i was i met her once i interviewed her
once with this little thing years later
thought she would not recognize me not
remember me she comes up to me at an
event saying hello like you know what
not a lot of people will do that i know
you know okay why do you think
i have a question why do men cheat like
really what's this is it anything to do
with the girls ask the boys no but i
have a question is this more is it more
because of the girl or is it something
that they just i mean from a girl's
perspective i mean maybe
i don't know do you all believe all once
a cheater always a cheater like i
there's so many things but
i don't know about all that but i i do
think in this particular situation
this is my synopsis i think emily
wears the pants she's the breadwinner
she's the star of the show in the
relationship
he's kind of just like next to her in
every photo like oh yeah you're dating
like the hottest woman in the world or
married i think this was his way of sort
of gaining power back trying to be the
dominant one yeah maybe it's an
insecurity i think 100 percent yeah it's
like a power trip thing so it honestly
has nothing to do with her has
everything to do with him
yes which is like
maybe sometimes like
when you do bring a newborn into a
relationship
i've heard that men sometimes get
jealous that the wife is now paying more
attention to this baby than you and it's
like
it just shows that dynamic i mean i
think it just shifts the whole
relationship because it's once you guys
were just the two of you focused on each
other and now you bring another that
needs more attention sorry it will die
without my attention what do you want
from me
you wanted this you put it in me yeah
oh god i can't imagine i mean like you
get sad about thinking about getting
cheated on when you're in a relationship
for like a year or two right like that
how devastating yeah and then think
about when you're married with a child
like how
hard that must be you think it's hard
and you try to work through it yeah
because there's a kid involved now it's
so sick that's the question is like now
you're locked in like you're signed a
contract here so it's debating like do
you want to break that contract and like
go find someone else which i think you
should but then or is it staying for the
kid which i also understand but i don't
know
i don't know i always think about like
is that once a chair always i always
also think about how um i'm pretty
convinced emily ratajkowski named her
baby after my dad yeah his name is
sylvester weird name to name someone
first of all sylvester middle name
apollo
apollo creed
rocky there's finally one trillion
percent there there's the best follow
interesting well if you're a fan you can
come hang out with us yeah we'll hang
out we'll hang out i mean we're just
like obviously spring but
we're still halfway there um but that
was really sad i hated reading that and
i think everyone's like losing their
[ __ ] on that
[Music]
gaps in the diet should not be ignored
over 97 of women ages 19 to 50 are not
getting enough vitamin d from their diet
and 95 are not getting their recommended
daily intake of key omega-3s rituals
essential for women 18 plus multivitamin
was formulated by with research to help
fill nutrient gaps in the diets of women
ages 18 plus it is formulated with
nutrients to help support brain health
bone health blood health and provide
antioxidant support but ritual didn't
stop there they invested in gold
standard university-led clinical trial
to prove that impact of essential for
women 18 plus multivitamins the results
you may ask essential for women 18 plus
was shown to increase vitamin d levels
by 43
and omega-3 dha levels by 41
in 12 weeks the clinical study was
published in leading scientific journal
frontiers in nutrition a published
clinical study is a big deal in a series
commitment to first of its kind standard
in the industry ritual is committed to
third-party testing from usp and the
non-gmo project traceable and
vegan-friendly ingredients and always
clear communication no shady stuff i
personally love taking rituals essential
for women 18 plus multivitamin because
it makes me feel like i'm taking care of
myself and i'm on top of my health i
agree and i absolutely love that it
doesn't hurt my stomach like a lot of
multivitamins do and i love that extra
nutrients are supporting the antioxidant
help that i've been looking for all
right on waxers if you want in on this
deal right now ritual is offering our
listeners 10 off your first three months
visit ritual.com
unwaxed and turn healthy habits into a
ritual that's 10 off you guys rachel.com
unwax
[Music]
oh do you know why i haven't slept
okay
my
um right above me my neighbors
party
until nice
4 30 in the morning
on a wednesday why don't you go join
them instead of being a little bit
first off who parties at until 4 30 on a
wednesday work week so obviously the
people above me don't have work the next
day because who can just like they were
drinking smoking blasting music
chatting their asses off on the balcony
so i heard every single conversation in
bed at like nine o'clock with her book
and her pimple cream she's like these
stupid kids well you know i'm like first
off i'm like realize that am i lame for
thinking that i'm like oh these
kids like
i definitely did like sit
out i opened my door and i kind of sat
outside it was just like listening to
conversations but
but i don't know if i could keep that
stamina up like i don't i don't know if
i've lost it or i just have not there
are a lot of young people in our
building yeah there is i just thought
that was pretty wild i don't know who
can do that on a wednesday at 4 30
drinking smoking and i don't know
honestly i think that the noise became
like a white noise and i fell asleep
eventually oh like ocean's house yeah
yeah but i wanted to kill you guys
because i really just killed my sleep
pattern
oh i had maybe like 20 minutes of rem
sleep so thank you very much i just
thought it was way too
much i actually i wrote this down um
i get all of my news on tick tock now
it's kind of embarrassing but i saw this
one question
and i'm gonna open it to the floor over
here
so all right this is the question
your wife is in labor and you're rushing
her to the hospital you get in a cab and
it turns out to be the cash cab do you
play or not
on the way to the hospital yeah
yeah yes yeah yeah he says no
yes yes
okay you can like you're the husband or
if you're the wife well you're both
you're the husband so
your wife is having contractions she's
dying she's like
but then it goes
be like those girls are
i think he would be expensive
we should do it and i think she would
look at him like are you [ __ ] well
isn't that basically the goal is to like
get to the end destination anyway so you
have like 10 blocks to isn't there a
possibility that they he pulls over and
kicks you out the cash cup if you lose
oh my god i feel like so that's the
thing right as long as she gets
thoughtful yeah that's the thing it's
like you so it's either you make it to
the hospital with like a normal cat
they you don't well it's a cash cab
you're planning
it's good for
you get to the rules yeah the cash cap
if you're playing the game it's a gamble
exactly so if you're gonna get in the
cash cab you gotta gamble that it's
either you're playing and you might get
kicked out if you're not smart enough so
it's really you have to think are you
smart enough to win to get your hallway
to the hospital time can you imagine dad
would crush it yeah yeah he knows every
answer on the cash flow yeah i know and
jeopardy is that just like an old person
thing like i feel like every time in new
york i hope i ran into the cash is that
even still no i every time i'm in new
york i i swear to god i look for billy
on the street
really is he i want billy eichner to
like run up to me and ask questions like
screaming for a dollar like i want to so
badly yeah i also really want to be on
like family feud it's really funny when
he brings like will ferrell and he goes
do you know who this is and everyone's
like no how humbling like you're so
famous and someone's like i don't know
who you are i think that's so funny i
love the ones with the christmas another
thing i did on i saw on tick tock was
this tampon prank that girls were doing
to their boyfriends and so i did it to
mine and this was my god funniest well
you have to explain so basically it's a
it's a joke that boys don't really
understand tampons right like you they
know about it they just don't really
know what the differences are the brands
whatever it does right so
i go babe you have to go into the store
like
can you just please go pick some up and
he's such a gent he's like oh my god
yeah of course like tell me what to look
for and it's like
this is so mean i said can you get the
coconut flavored tampons
and then he's like i don't see coconut
i'm like okay what do you find like
lemon like i like the lemon-lime ones
it's like this kid so he's getting
around in the aisles looking for lime
flavored tampons
this poor boy doesn't know at all what
that even means like how do you but
things if i were him i probably would
have looked at the colors and then like
oh green means lime you know or like
yellow means long because it's regular
why don't they have flavored tampons why
would you have flavor tampons
no but you know some people like soak
their
yeah like some people soak their
yeah but gabby some people soak their
tampon in like tequila to get drunk
what's the difference by the way i was
just thinking about that you guys know
that that people soak
that
psychopath that would burn that would
hurt
like i don't you really have to want to
get really like you have to want to get
drunk very badly if you were doing that
as a last resort option life hack like
getting into festivals so could you have
money too
and whatever it's so funny okay i don't
think anyone uses facebook anymore i
only go on it to see which one of my
college high school friends uh are
getting married and a lot of them are
and a lot of them are under the age of
uh
25 which i'm just like am i i'm either
aging myself a lot am i trying to what
what are you doing i think i just
started a chat with one of your old
kisses yeah that's the point but don't
don't click it oh sorry you don't click
it's my chat oh okay okay
so
um so
something i did yesterday and you guys
should definitely do this is
go back
so far into your facebook chat rooms
oh
my god the [ __ ] you see in 2009 that you
were sending to your crush is so funny i
know mine is because i'll tell you this
i i think i have a little bit of game
now i'm a little bit better with
flirting no i am you can't don't give me
that look i'm goof i'm dorky whatever
but like i'm definitely a bit more cool
with things stop that sistine don't give
me that i just have a question what what
what about you
is dorky
hot girls can't be dorky sophia you
don't think i'm dorky you literally call
me a dork all the time mom daughter
called you a dork it's your life you
call yourself you guys call me like a
what but what's dorky
the way like i just like dork out about
things like books or whatever that guy
she's a dork out i don't know like i
know i think watching i think you're
more like goofy
yeah i said isn't dorky and goofy the
same thing no
it's not goofy's like you like you're
saying funny things today or silly oh my
god okay fine goofy
goofy so i was way goofier
so did not need to even get into that
whatever you are not a door so
you're not a dark you're only goofy um
but i really wasn't i wasn't cool like
we all we all know the stories of me
having a stye eating chocolate muffins
guy muffin girl muffin girl flash drive
around her neck writing short stories we
get it like had pointed glasses at the
end and braces like we had bangs that
were we got
she's evil by the way i think you got
your revenge on me the other day because
i had a stun yeah sophia was like now
you're star horse girl
she's been waiting like 10 years to say
that and i didn't even stutter when i
said that i was so ready for that moment
she's like i've been waiting forever for
this
moment and everyone in the family guys i
except knees i was like
like 15 years later he came back
but i was reading these messages and i
was like oh my god i'm so embarrassing
no they're pretty cringey so i found
this message i want to read this
and i want to shout out to my first kiss
i don't know if i should say his name my
first name matt hi um
and this is in 2009. my first kiss
was
i was 17.
i was 17. no don't give me up
for 13. i was 13. no it was bad
i was scared this isn't when i had a
first kiss i haven't had my first kiss
yet this was just like in general so
these messages are from 2009 so i'm 13
years old and you know
sophia sophia you're like
so the first message i go up and it's 10
10 09 right at 6 00 pm i say if i tell
you who i like you have to tell me first
who you like
oh
somebody else and then he goes ha ha
well okay but it's not like i don't
really know it kind of depends i need to
think about it if i'm telling the
complete truth sounds normal he just pi
he just pied you
guys okay
i had a severe crush on him so this is
already being set up really poorly but
he doesn't answer for like four hours
and then i immediately answered i go
okay if you tell the honest truth about
who you like i will be honest too
he goes but i am being totally honest it
really depends please tell me i'm sorry
for pressuring you don't tell me if you
don't want to just wondering my fault
and i go come on
say my name god damn it
what is wrong with you
[Applause]
come on you have to have someone you
like
say it again ask him one more time
[Laughter]
wait
okay
this guy my mom i can't tell you when i
say this ends like a plane crash it's so
embarrassing wait you have to talk
because i can't understand you
come on you have to have someone you
like oh
i thought you were dating shira if i
said anything mean or offensive and i
smelled that so wrong
i'm really sorry all caps actually
if you said anything mean or offensive
i'm really sorry no it gets worse it
gets so much worse ready
he goes ha no i'm not into anyone we
broke up a couple weeks ago so it
depends just you say it first i go wait
dot dot dot
i know you like exclamation point
me caps
oh
[ __ ]
then he says ha ha sophia just he write
like ha ha sophia just tell me okay fine
dot dot dot i'll tell you
then it gets
radio silence so i remember in between
this i think i called him and i told him
i liked him and he told me that he
didn't like me back
no
so this is cut too so that wasn't that
was 10 10 that was like whatever you go
this is hard this is 10 24.
i write to him
this is so bad
um hey matt i know we haven't talked in
a while and i feel like after i told you
i liked you everything was just awkward
i just want to tell you i don't have a
crush on you anymore but i really like
you as a bff elf
yeah so bye
what do you say
um
and he never answered
sophia
i would like to tell you i had read this
in real time
i would have thrown your computer in the
pool and stopped this madness by the way
that was literally
one
of so many
so many horrible things i mean that was
probably the best one out of all i know
i have good ones too
but my account was deleted i am
but i i really i really feel bad for
sophia in 2009. she really had no game
did not know how to text like a normal
person she's just too sweet but like
really wanted him to like but by the way
guess what he ended up being my first
kiss years later ha boom boom so i guess
it worked
and it goes down in the dms literally
okay but i just thought those were funny
so if you ever want to just make
yourself cry laugh and also cringe at
yourself please go back
if you have funny messages like that
from when you're young on facebook
submit them oh please submit them to our
unboxed email that is in our instagram
bio or dm them to us and we will read
them on the show yeah they i love those
actually that's a really good one we
should cut down in the dms that's our
segment
okay i know we have a lot of random
segments but that's a good one okay
so
another segment sophia and i used to do
all the time
was our bedtime story segment
[Music]
basically sofia and i would share any
sort of story whether it was personal
deep and sad
embarrassing funny and we would just
like you guys i don't know if you
remember sistine talking about how two
of the guys she's made out with had
bloody noses on her okay i accidentally
flashed her ex-boyfriend by smashing my
boobs in the window not knowing he was
there i forgot you did that yeah that
was pretty bad you did windshield wipers
with your boobs yeah because you did it
because you did it first and you didn't
tell me
yeah she did it first didn't tell me he
was in the room so of course i'm doing
what i remember so vividly the rest of
that night he was like he couldn't he no
he like wouldn't touch me and i was like
do you like her now what's going on like
what's up
sorry not sorry no but it was really
horrible um so
those type of bedtime stories i'm gonna
share our bedtime story today if you
guys want your bedtime story read make
sure you go to the email in our unwaxed
bio or you go to our reviews and ratings
five star write it there we'll read it
yes well also if it's too private and
you don't want it to be like public
public unless we want to say it
to email and then i also can give you
more options of what you want to hear
next week from us for our bedtime story
if you want to but we're going to let
cysteine kick it off this time so
this is a little bit of an embarrassing
one
for myself
i was at a birthday dinner for my mom a
few years ago
and
i was told at the dinner that my first
boyfriend
was recently hit
by a bus
and i was like
what i i i do not know about how did i
not know i immediately went into shock
and i was told that he was in a coma and
he wasn't well and i was like what the
[ __ ] i started crying i was freaking out
for him i was so sad i didn't know
whether i should reach out yeah i didn't
know if i should text his mom so for
like three days i was spiraling like i
did not know what to do so i a few days
later i sat with it i decided to text
his mom
should i pull it up
while we're really reading just messages
today i win something along the lines of
i heard about your son and i'm so sorry
and i'm praying for your family and this
is a really sad and scary time if you
need anything i'm here for you all the
stuff
she writes back thank you sweetie that
was the nicest message ever i really
appreciate your thoughts and your
prayers
but i have no idea what you're talking
about
and
he's fine yeah he's been fine he's
actually playing his sport right now no
coma
no no como no boss no late como no okay
no what does that call it
it's like combo no not like combo
yeah we've been saying coma no pine cone
no any cones no traffic cones he was
fine so i feel like a schmuck can you
imagine if i texted him and my thought
process was she was about to like i was
going to text him but i was like he's in
a coma he's in a coma right he's not
going to read it
how [ __ ] embarrassing
whoever told you that
is unbelievable for telling you that it
was a very reliable who i thought
trustworthy source no no it really it
was a person you would never expect just
make that also how do you make that up
how do you know why how do you just give
yourself the great vibe false
information and then also drop it
casually so then i respond like
well that's great news uh he's great
then healthy as a horse
i can't even imagine being a mom and
getting that message being like
embarrassing that if she's like thank
you for your prayers
what are you talking about i don't we
don't really need the perfect prayer for
his next uh match i just feel like such
a schmuck
like
this is the first time you hear from me
in years and like the mom really liked
you and she that it was like the first
time in years years that she's ever
reached out i'm glad it wasn't i mean
imagine being him and getting that
message like from your ex coming like
i'm just so sorry you got hit by a
button he's like he's wearing this
before a birthday text you [ __ ] what do
you have to text me for my birthday but
you text me when i'm in like just beyond
god so bad but we're definitely gonna
bring that was a good one thank you i
don't think anyone can i mean if anyone
has something similar that's so funny
well we have a few options for our next
week's bedtime scene so you guys can
tell me which one you want to hear but
yeah there's one punching my high school
boyfriend in the face on the first date
option one splitting my hood open in
first grade yeah okay
staying in front of american idol
producers and choked did you do that
yeah
i know um and then falling between a
refrigerator and a wall after my first
kiss with an x i love that story it is
that one's over like you fell into a
fridge that was so funny
when i say it oh god and yeah it's just
tragic sophia so tragic i have so many
endless ones of those i honestly those
were just like four i thought of in two
seconds so
so to wrap this episode
like we did in the past we're gonna end
it with some unsolicited advice if you
guys want your questions answered make
sure you go to the ratings and review
page
leave five stars and then leave your
question in the comments that is the
only way we are going to answer it so
here we go take you seriously anymore
this listener wrote in
my ex said he still wants to get back
together but has a girlfriend help
it seems like this listener's in the
room
try to share this
therapy session sure
um here's the advice i gave to this
mysterious listener sitting across from
me
well
he uh wants to get back together how's
the girlfriend our ex has a girlfriend
and basically said everything but like i
guess your first question would be
why does he want to get back together
with you
no why not in a mean way but
he has a relationship
right he he's already in one
so
honestly what is the reason for breaking
up with someone to get with someone else
is it because he misses the old ways is
it because he's not happy in his current
one and like you're comfortable like
finding the intention of why someone
wants to leave a relationship to get
into another one is very important
that's actually true because if they're
going into it saying like this is
someone that's just always around like
that's not always a good intention like
you wanted to be like
deeper than you missed
this relationship
you know what you need to play that song
what's the one that that's
what is it glimpse of us glimpse of us
sounds like your soundtrack glimpse of
us and your answer will be there
that's like learning the worst advice
next question
listen to a song you're back i actually
have to say
nearly all that's your answer
whatever that's all i got for you
i have to say all of them put my hair by
willow smith stop
most of the questions we got were dating
advice questions oh i love those because
this one is absolutely great at those
advice for a girl who's never been on a
date love you guys love you too all
right advice for a girl who's never been
on a date
oh mm-hmm like what that's very
that's a very broad question okay i i'll
say this i remember on my first few
dates i was very nervous and i was
always thinking about oh i don't know
what to say and i don't know what to ask
my best advice is people always love
talking about themself so just ask a lot
of questions and then he'll leave being
like that was the best day at ever she's
so interested
also
don't put so much energy where you feel
like you're taking over the conversation
because then that ends up becoming
that's me
where it becomes you actually don't know
the person across from you there's three
things i wish i did when i was starting
to date it's one
really be myself immediately on the
first date like be the goofy whatever
chatty person i have always been because
then you'll know pretty much off the bat
whether or not you have a connection
with this person i think
not worrying so much about the little
details and everything yeah no don't put
pressure on the fact whether they're
gonna call you again the next day
because every time you go on a first
date it might not be one that's gonna
stick but that's the point of dating but
the thing about first dates especially
in the first few months is because
you're so new at this you don't really
know what you like or what you don't
like yet so really take this time when
you're going on these dates to
figure out what you were expecting
because that's a good point yeah because
i feel like now that we've i've been
i've been dating since like now high
school i now know exactly what i want
yeah
you know for yourself just to figure out
what you do so just figure it out like
date don't put so much pressure on it
but be note like be aware of what makes
you feel happy like maybe if you text me
the next day you're like oh i like when
guys and i need yeah or i don't mind if
he doesn't call until tomorrow like
you'll figure that out the more you go
but just like ease into it remember
you're learning everyone's learning and
yeah you're going to figure it out so
thank you all right here's one that you
can answer what is cysteine's weakness
what is sistine's weakness i have a few
cat videos like kitten videos she loves
those yes yeah she loves a good bowl of
risotto these answers are
so random
risotto and kittens
i thought you're gonna be like a large
body of water
like women yeah you don't even know
weakness i thought like a good weakness
like i said like it makes a week in the
knees not like a scary weekend oh she
can't
swim um she's really bad at choosing a
hair colorist she'll dye her hair orange
and black and accidentally gently what
else is spiders she hates spiders
yeah she really hates spiders feet
yeah she doesn't like feet uh she
doesn't like when i hug her it freaks
her out
um the honestly only
exactly
just me though
yeah i don't like rolling roller
coasters you like scary movies
i'm just trying to think about other
things make you weak
um
next question yeah i don't know any new
book recommendations
i'll leave that to you go to favorite
book club that's where you'll find a lot
right good morning monster is great this
one's
a little triggering sistine were you
ever classified as the weird horse girl
how did you handle this yes i just
classified her that a couple days you
know
but with a stye i think horse girls have
a really bad rep like they're super
weird they're not you are weird but
they're not weird they're just it seems
like chai's not cooler than she is like
i think i'm
like you're weird
with a lot of things sophia but being a
horse girl is like
so much cooler than reading books all
day sorry you're a book girl i'm a horse
girl
this is great okay
how do i handle it just own it live my
life i don't care yeehaw when is it too
soon to define the relationship two
months of seeing each other i don't
think it's too soon two months ago it's
a long time you know 60 days it kind of
i'll tell you this if it hits three
months and you guys still haven't
actually defined what you are dump him
dump him i'm just kidding don't jump no
yes
no bring it up bring it up because
here's the thing first month you're like
okay i'm still seeing if i like him
second month you're like okay i'm seeing
if i could actually become at least
exclusive with him yeah
third month and they're not making
things official
then and you want something official
then if you don't bring it up or if you
do and he doesn't want it then
sayonara but you have to live the same
way if you're wanting something to be
serious and one-on-one you gotta put
that energy into becoming that you can't
be like playing around and be like what
are we like you gotta if you're
committed to this person be committed
stick with it and if they're not
committed then you go
you know this person wrote in advice on
feeling lost i'm feeling like just lost
in general yeah i think you know what i
think everyone goes through
a moment feeling that way i know i felt
that way a few months ago
and you when you're in that rut of
feeling like
however you define lost
you almost think that you're never gonna
get out of it and you're never going to
feel the way that you once felt and
you're just stuck and no one will
understand you and
but you're kind of creating these habits
and these bad things in your head
allowing yourself to be there but it's
good to remember that it's not permanent
and we always say this like you're gonna
wake up with a new feeling tomorrow
whether it's worse or better or sadder
or happier it's a new feeling so it's
not gonna be consistent but the one
advice i can give you if you're
consistently lost and you feel like
there hasn't been a change you got to do
something in your own life that is
definitely yeah it's not going to get
better you can't like think about it if
you're drawing a straight line and it's
not going up it's not going down it's
just still the same you gotta
you gotta like knock that curve you
gotta make something happen where
even if it makes you happy for two hours
even if it's just taking a walk on the
beach just something like that you know
i just think that's important when
you're feeling lost is to find something
to do i agree
this person wrote what to wear on a
first date first or second date
there's actually a science to this
there's a there's a science if you're a
girl guys love like
honestly what guys like sundress is long
it is sunday season yeah yeah if you're
waiting for summer i think that's pretty
and girly but if you like jeans wear
jeans i don't know just i honestly
what it's like do you here's what i like
to do
don't wear sweatpants here's my pajamas
like i like to look classy but also a
little sexy see if you're wearing top
and bottom sexy too much we're not going
to the club yeah if you're wearing
classy classy on the top and bottom you
look like a nun so i would wear a long
pencil skirt with perhaps
a crop top or some sort of v-neck
bodysuit or i'll do a turtleneck with a
short little leather skirt yeah switch
it up i'm like that too like i love a
good dress that i can like you need me
my decollete is showing but it's like
long dress so it's not like very
seductive but it's girly long dress is
always so good they hit yeah it's so
good let's see last question advice for
jealousy in a friends with benefits
situation
oh
friends with benefits does not
work it's not real the movie with justin
timberlake and mila kuni they ended up
dating it's a lie because they are
getting jealous and that's exactly the
point
they're gonna act like one person or
both parties in a friends of benefit
situation is gonna act like they don't
care and they don't want a relationship
or they're never going to be jealous but
someone always catches feelings i'll
tell you this this is my recommendation
watch no strings attached and you're
going to get your answer what do you do
you don't do it here's the thing when
you're having sex with someone
it's not just physical a lot of
emotional mental goes into it
and all of your hormones are going up
and your endorphins are raised and
you're feeling euphoric and then you're
associating that feeling with liking
that person because now you're
comfortable with them in an intimate way
so then you're going to be like oh wait
in your head what would it look like if
we were together and then you start
liking them and then the guy or the girl
starts dating someone else and they'll
be ju yeah
and just rewind and just in case some
people are out there going like i can
handle it blah blah good for you you
have to know yourself and you know
yourself if you can handle a friends
with benefit situation
and you know that you won't get jealous
and you're not that type truly at your
heart our hearts and be really look
yourself in the mirror and be like i
don't catch feelings that often then do
it but if you are someone like me i
can't do casual dating i've never been
that way i i will catch feelings and
quickly
okay
um
go on
yeah yeah i know
no i'm just saying just be honest with
yourself if you know you're going to
catch feelings don't do that stuff
because you're only going to get hurt in
the end and the more you get hurt the
more trust issues you have and you don't
want to go through life with a ton of
trust issues it's really hard to recover
from that so um no you don't and that i
think wraps i loved this episode i love
sister episodes this is great sister
yeah okay well you guys remember give us
a five-star rating and review by the way
podcast because we do read those we did
hit five stars there was a one star
saying we talk over each other
then leave peace out you don't have to
be here all right this is the way we
work
we talk a lot with
chatty pipe it okay um five stops five
stars only if anything lasts we're gonna
find you um
we're gonna kill you
we'll see you next tuesday bye
[Music]
you